only on c-span 2
created by the cable television industry
next on encore book notes charles
fetcher discusses his work editing the
diary of h.l menken he describes the
unsealing of menkin's personal papers in
1985 which led to the publishing of the
diary
mr fetcher talks about menkin's work at
the baltimore sun as well as his views
on contemporaries including f scott
fitzgerald and franklin delano roosevelt
it's just under an hour
charles fetcher
editor of the diary of h.l menken what's
been the most surprising thing
that's happened since the publication
uh the the uproar surrounding the
publication i was totally unprepared for
anything like this
i expected that the book would generate
some controversy because h.l megan never
wrote a book that didn't but i did not
expect
what happened
who uproard the most
uh reviewers and critics
all critical
uh no no not all by any means the the
initial reaction was highly critical
of mankind
but then some calmer voices began to be
heard
and i would say that at the present time
the reaction
is about 50 pro and 50 khan
is there anything to criticize
him for as a result of this information
uh the diary reveals a strain of
anti-semitism
of racism
of what the
media has called bigotry
uh
it reveals a pro-german
sympathy
that sort of thing uh you know none of
this was entirely new anyone who was
familiar with mankind's work
uh would have known that those things
were in there it's simply that in the
diary they are stated
more strongly and starkly
than they ever were in what he published
during his own lifetime
let's start at the beginning who is h.l
menken h l menken was a newspaper man
magazine editor author
uh philologist
and uh critic of
the national morays
from about the turn of the century 1900
uh up until the time of his death in
1956.
he he reached the peak of his reputation
in the 1920s and 30s
when walter lipman called him the most
powerful personal influence on this
whole generation of educated people
and the new york times called him the
most powerful private citizen in america
what's a philologist a philologist is a
person who studies the origins and
meanings of words
mankind wrote a book called the american
language
which is a study of the way that the
english language developed in the united
states
he published the first edition in 1919
there were second and third editions
in 1921 and 23.
in 1936 he totally rewrote the entire
book to bring out a fourth edition
and then subsequently he brought out two
supplements to that edition so what you
have are four thick volumes
run uh six thick volumes
running to about 3 800 pages
of study of the american language of the
english language in the united states
where did he live
in baltimore his life long he was born
there lived there and died there and he
lived in one of the city's typical brick
front row houses for all but about eight
of his 75 years and where do you live
i live
in a similar
community called govens in north
baltimore which again is row houses
where did these diaries come from
when mankind died he left the diary
along with a mass of other papers to the
enoch pratt free library in baltimore
enoch
pratt and what's that it is baltimore's
public library
and mankind had used it from the time he
was nine years old
uh all of his papers were deposited with
the pratt library
the diary and some other papers were
given to them with a stipulation that
they could not be opened until 25 years
after his death
and the 25th anniversary of his death
was in january of 1981
but it wasn't until a number of years
after that
that the library uh
decided to publish the diary
how did you get involved
well uh in 1978 i published a book on
mankind called mankind to study this
thought
which was also published by alfred a
knopf the publisher of all of menkin's
books
and the publisher of the diary
when it was decided to publish the diary
i of course
applied
it submitted my application for the job
there were any number of other
applications i know
of the various applicants the library
selected me what were you doing before
that
are you a writer by training uh
well i
would like to say that i am a writer
i've never made a living at it uh
i worked for a good many years for the
archdiocese of baltimore
in various capacities and retired from
there in 1980 till
i've been retired since
uh i suppose some of the considerations
that led them to give me the job of
editing the diary
uh or the fact that i had written the
other book about him
uh the fact that i was a native
baltimorean and knew the whole
background many of the people he talks
about in the diary
and was retired so i could give it my
full time
when did you first get interested in h.l
menken
uh so far back that i can hardly
tell you when it first happened
uh mankin wrote a series of articles for
the evening sun the baltimore evening
sun
they were known as the monday articles
they appeared on the editorial page of
the evening sun
every monday from 1920 until 1938
and i first became acquainted with him
in
those monday articles
uh
i i don't go back to 1920
but i can't remember
uh the the later years you know the
middle 30s
uh i fell in love with his style his
manner of expression
and with his ideas and this began a love
affair that has gone on ever since
i bought his various books as they came
out
and uh
read everything by and about him that i
could get a hold of
if you go to the national press club
here in washington there's a h l menken
library and
as we're talking a major controversy is
whether or not to continue calling it
the h.l menken library yes i know why or
uh
because of the anti-semitism and racism
expressed in the diary
the national press club felt that they
did not want their library to be named
after a person with
with these ideas
and the proposal has been made to
take his name off of the library
uh i would hope that uh calmer minds
will prevail
and that the proposal will not go
through
why
because menken was above all else a
newspaper man he was probably the
greatest journalist
this country has ever seen
uh and the national press club and
naming its library after him
recognized that fact
and the fact is not changed
because the diary reveals some
disagreeable aspects of his personality
reveals his weaknesses as well as his
strengths
are there people that are genuinely
shocked by what they read here and
surprised yes yes there's no question
about that
should they be
i suppose they have every right to be
i said earlier that anyone who knows
mankind's work would have been prepared
for this
if you did not know menken very well
then the anti-semitism and the racism
revealed in the diary
would come as a shock
from your perspective what what was it
about his writing that made him so good
primarily i would say the style no other
man in american literature has ever
written like him his style is utterly
unique he's one of the great humorists
in american literature
uh there are passages by him that you
can't read without bursting into guf
awes
now you know style is only one aspect of
writer's equipment uh he must also have
ideas
to express
and and mankind did uh the the range of
his uh interests and activities was
enormous he wrote about politics
literature
uh civic affairs
uh politicians
uh
mostly i would say politicians
what do you think of politicians uh he
didn't like any of them he said that a
good politician is as unthinkable as an
honest burglar
no politician at all that he liked uh in
in theory yes in actual practice there
were of course men who he knew
personally and liked and respected
let me read from your introduction okay
roosevelt this is uh franklin roosevelt
was a quote world saver
his political and economic premises were
quote so false as to be absurd
the conclusions he drew from these those
premises were quote always dubious and
sometimes completely idiotic
is that strong for mankind no that that
for mankind that's rather mild
uh he wrote about all presidents of the
united states like this
you describe
an appearance by the president uh
roosevelt fdr in front of the gridiron
club and uh that mr macon was sitting
there in the audience can you tell us
about that
uh mankind had been invited to be the
speaker at this dinner of the gridiron
club in 1934 i think it was
uh he gone up and delivered what was a
critical
but essentially
good-natured and humorous
uh
talk about roosevelt's new deal and of
course he found plenty of fault with it
he claimed that the only provision of
the constitution that had not been
violated by the new deal
was the uh prohibition of quartering
soldiers in people's private homes
a little later it was the president's
turn to speak
he got up and began
a vicious attack
on newspapermen and journalism
an attack that had cold chills running
up and down the spines of the people
listening to him
finally they realized that what he was
doing was reading a piece called
journalism in america which had been
written by mankind himself
and published in his magazine the
american mercury
so uh you know the president was
attacking
journalists
and and mankind in menkin's own words
menken felt publicly humiliated by this
and swore that he would get even
although of course there was really no
way that he could ever get even except
to write more and more bitter attacks
upon roosevelt and the great iron club
the room was full of journalists yes of
course
you also write in your introduction
he had castigated and ridiculed presence
before almost as a matter of policy
harding the num skull
coolidge a cheap and trashy fellow a
dreadful little cad
hoover
where his car where his character ought
to be there is almost a blank
did uh did this have any impact on the
public oh yes i think so
how
uh because of his enormous reputation as
a political commentator
and journalist
these monday articles in the baltimore
evening sun that i spoke of
uh were
known and uh
quoted all over the country but you
could only read them in the baltimore
evening center i i think they were
syndicated in some papers
go back to uh 1956 that was the year of
his death yes had you ever have you ever
met him no no he never did
have you talked to people who have met
him oh yes a number of them yes what was
he like to know
according to everybody who ever knew him
he was one of the kindest most courteous
most gentle and most considerate persons
you can imagine
how did he write i mean when did he
write what was his style uh he wrote
with obligion
he he hurled thunderbolts at everybody
was he a morning writer an afternoon
writer did he uh
did he write with a typewriter longhand
all his work was done as a typewriter
uh my impression is
that most of his work was done in the
afternoon and evening
was he a drinker
uh
yes he was if you mean by that was he an
alcoholic
no by no means he was a very careful and
cagey drinker
uh among his friends were authors like
sinclair lewis and scott fitzgerald
and he blames them for the fact that
what he considered their excessive
drinking
had destroyed their their literary gifts
and he himself had very careful rules
about what
when
and where he drank
and uh you know there is no record that
he was ever at any time
uh
under the influence of
you say
let it be said at once clearly and
unequivocably equivocally that menken
was an anti-semite and then you go on to
uh
the difficulty in reading all this it
just fuels the whole
discussion and and that's why i hesitate
um he you go on to write that uh
lawrence spivak who was to become
publisher of the mercury is a young
harvard jew the young harvard jew is
quote unquote from menkin uh is that the
same large spivak that went on to do
meat yes yes it is
the wife of a distinguished johns
hopkins professor is characterized in
two words french jewish
charles angov enghof
no hangover uh quote like most of the
other young jewish intellectuals unquote
inclines toward communism samuel elliott
morrison the great historian is quoted
as telling him that the students in his
class at johns hopkins are quote mainly
jews why was this such a bother to him
i i don't know uh you know i i can't
pretend to explain it
uh
there there was unquestionably
uh an overt or i should say a covert
uh anti-semitism in the air and culture
of that time
uh it wasn't the kind of
psychotic and murderous anti-semitism
that occurred in germany with the rise
of the nazis it was a more quiet thing i
i know that in my own baltimore and i
suppose this is true of other cities too
uh there were neighborhoods that were
restricted in quotes
but this meant the jews could not move
into them
there were clubs the jews could not be
long till
uh there were swimming pools the jews
could not go in
and there were lots of other
restrictions
placed upon them
uh what was his religion
lincoln did not believe in anything did
he go to the church ever no he was a
strict diagnostic
um
one of the ironies uh that this book is
published this the diary here hold up to
the art you can see is published by
kanav publishers
and mr kanoff was jewish yes and one of
megan's closest friends when did is he
still alive no no he died uh five or six
years ago i think was there ever any
consideration by the kunoff publishing
company
that by publishing these diaries they're
fueling the whole anti-semitism again
i i'm not aware of any such
consideration
uh i mean in the course of your
conversations with them that never came
up and they're never worried about
nothing uh
at the beginning of my work on the diary
when i was just getting started on it
i wrote to the senior vice president and
editor
at knopf pointing out to us these things
were in there and that to do an honest
editing job
uh it would be necessary to
to use them
and he wrote back and said uh he agreed
completely and that
there was no point in trying to cover
them up
start with the diaries um
how did he keep these diaries
uh
he began them in 1930 when he was
already 50 years old
and for a while he kept at it fairly
regularly not not daily by any means
there might be long stretches of several
weeks where he wouldn't touch it and
then there might be a period where he
would
you know make an entry almost every day
in 1935 his wife died
and after that for a long time he gave
it up almost entirely
it wasn't until like 1937 or 38
uh that he resumed it on anything like a
regular basis
uh
and then in the 1940s he really took it
seriously the the entries for those
years
uh are lengthy
uh he did it as typewriter
as i said he never wrote anything in
longhand
uh the
result i suppose is starting out in life
as a newspaper reporter
uh
about half the diaries in his own typing
about half of it is in the typing of the
secretary mrs larfink
and did he only keep these diaries for
18 years
yes
that's it that's it
now when you started with this when did
you physically start with this project
about
1987 i suppose 1986 or 87
and once you showed up to work one day
where did you go and what did somebody
hand you
well
the pratt library handed me the total
diary
uh it was it was boxed in in five
volumes it was sealed in five boxes let
us say
each one with a label on it initially by
him
saying that it was not to be opened
until 25 years after his death
uh
i was given a xerox
copy all the way through from beginning
to end of the diary
and the first thing i had to do was make
a selection this this by the way is by
no means the total diary
the diary runs to something like 2 100
pages of double space typing which would
make three books the size of that one
how many words is that i would estimate
it to somewhere between five hundred
thousand and six hundred thousand
uh so the first thing i had to do was
make a selection
and get it down to a volume of
manageable size
uh what you see here in this book was
what i selected and it is about
one-third
of the total diary are you going to do
another
no there are no plans to bring out
the unused two-thirds
now when you had a glance at this first
in 1987
there had been a period between 1981 and
1987 that these diaries were allowed to
be seen by someone
the library made them available to
those who had already established
themselves as mankind scholars
people who had written books or articles
about him who were engaged upon research
about him and they made them available
to scholars in some related fields for
example there was a man
at that time doing a history of the
baltimore sun papers for
the occasion of its 150th anniversary
and you know this book is loaded with
material about the sun papers so you
know the diary was made available to him
uh but it was not generally available
and even those who were allowed to see
it
had to swear solemnly in writing that
they would not quote from it or
paraphrase it or use it in any way in
their writings
there was a problem
getting a decision
to actually publish why
i spoke of the fact that there were was
a label on each one of the boxes
initialed by him
that label said that it was not to be
opened until 25 years after his death
and that even after that it was to be
made available only to scholars engaged
in serious research
uh this created the problem or uh
brought up the question
did menken ever intend the diary to be
published at all
the board of trustees of the pratt
library debated this question for a long
time
and they sought a legal ruling from
stephen h sachs who was at that time
attorney general of the state of
maryland
as to whether in view of what was said
on the labels
the library
could publish them
mr sachs ruled that the labels did not
have the legal formality
uh required for wills
and that therefore the library was
within its rights in publishing them do
you think that h.l mencken would be
pleased that these diaries were
published
i don't think menken ever wrote a single
word
that he didn't envisage being published
sometime
so i i think yes he would be pleased and
doubtless highly amused by all the
reaction to it put the actual diaries
into context with everything else he was
doing i mean this wasn't the only
writing he was doing during these 18
years
and what was the style of writing the
diaries compared to other things well
the diaries are much rougher
they don't have the finished polish
style of the published books
uh
they don't have the high humor of the
published books
and this is not to say that they're
serious or some are in tune they're not
uh it was impossible for him to write
anything
somber
even when he's complaining about his
health which he says constantly through
here
you say he was a hypochondriac oh god
yes yes one of the worst in the world
was he really was he sick very often
oh there's no doubt that in later years
his health declined
uh he was really a candidate for high
blood pressure and a stroke
and of course this was a stroke that
eventually finished his career
uh
i i don't know how much of the
complaining about his health in the
diary was genuine and how much was just
hypochondria at uh at what time did he
would he write the diary compared to
everything else he was writing during a
day was at the end of the day i i would
imagine so there's no indication
uh as i said about half of it is his own
typing
and half of it is in the typing of the
secretary
it's very easy to distinguish between
them
apparently on days when he had the time
and i would imagine that this was late
in the you know sometime after dinner
uh he would
sit down at his own typewriter
and type a diary entry
uh when time did not permit he would
dictate it to his secretary along with
the mail he had for her
and she would type it
you've got a lot of photographs in here
and i want to hold a couple of them up
and and take a look at them and have you
explain what they are
uh on the screen right now is a
photo of
mr menken and who
george g nathan
who was a close friend of menkins and
incidentally also jewish
uh they worked on the smart set magazine
for
from 1908 to 1923.
mankin was the book editor nathan was
the drama critic
in 1914 they became the co-editors of
the magazine
and it was during those years that they
both became famous for their
their irreverence
their pungent style
and for the influence they had on
in menkin's case
literature in nathan's case the drama
what's this picture below
that is a picture taken on boston common
at the time of the famous hat rack case
which occurred in 1926.
is making in this picture uh yes he's
the one holding up that sheet of paper
in the center
uh he was editor of the american mercury
magazine by then uh he and nathan gave
up the smart set at the end of 1923 and
started a new magazine called the
american mercury at the beginning of
1924
uh which immediately became one of the
most influential
magazines
of of that period
uh
in 1926 in april i believe it was
the magazine was banned in boston by an
organization called the watch and ward
society
uh because of an article in it called
half rack
the the story of a prostitute in a
little midwestern town
uh a man named chase who had at the
watching ward society
uh thought that the article was obscene
and uh ordered
all boston newsstands and book dealers
not to sell it now chase's society had
no legal standing whatever
but it had such enormous influence that
book dealers
and newsstands were afraid to buck him
so they took it off of their stands
uh mankind heard about this and went up
to boston
and sold a copy of the magazine on
boston common and was promptly arrested
for
selling obscene
literature
uh the next morning when the case came
up in court the judge who had read
hathrac the night before threw the case
out of court he said that there was no
evidence of uh obscenity in it at all
so you know there mankind won although
in the long haul he lost
because chase succeeded in having the
issue
barred from the males
now this was a moot point since it's
already been mailed out anyway
but it was necessary to go through a
long hearing before the postmaster
general
and
there menken lost
he and his publisher cannot consider
taking the case to the supreme court but
it would have been too long and
too expensive and they never did
i have a photo here in just a moment of
uh
h.l menken and
second wife
no he was only married only married once
yes
he married at the age of 50 in 1930. um
i know it confused me you say he she
died in 1935 that's right and they were
only married for how long five years
what impact did she have on his life a
tremendous one
uh he had met her seven years before
they got married
and there's no doubt that he was deeply
and romantically smitten by her from the
very beginning
there was an 18-year age difference
between them
uh
when they married he was 50 and she was
30 kill
she
was in poor health
she had a number of serious
operations over the time that he knew
her
when he married her the doctors told
him that she did not have more than
three years to live
actually she lived five
uh and
he says in the diary you know they were
the five
happiest and most fulfilling years of
his life
and there's no doubt that her death left
a tremendous void
in his life and not all of his
activities ever suffice to fill that up
why did she have so much impact on him
why did she have someone what was it
about the relationship that
what does he say about the relationship
that was so important to him she was a
beautiful charming intelligent woman
and he never married before that or
after that's right yes what did her
death do to him and what what what can
you read through the diaries that
give you an impression of uh the fact
that uh he writes so often uh of how
much he misses her
the hardly a day goes by that he doesn't
think of her didn't he say even
somewhere in one of these
uh one of the entries that the hour
doesn't go by without him thinking yeah
yes that's right yes probably so and
every day he thinks of something he
wants to tell her or see something that
he wants to buy for her
another photograph of
h.l making by the way what does hl stand
for henry lewis
who is he named after
anybody
uh
henry was the name of his uncle
uh who lived next door to them by the
way
and louis uh
was the name of a long since
dead
uh child of his
grandfathers by another marriage this
child died in infancy was named louis
and for some reason uh which nobody
could possibly figure out today
little henry was named was given the
middle name lewis
did he always part his hair down the
middle yes
did he ever say why
no nothing i'm aware of when was this
picture taken the little one the little
one about
i think about 1942
and the one below it the one below it is
i believe dated 1939
uh
it's the backyard garden of their row
house of 1524 holland street in west
baltimore and he and his brother spent a
tremendous amount of time in the garden
uh
planting flowers in the spring and
pulling them up in the fall and enjoying
them in between
what was politics
uh he was an incurable conservative and
tory
any reason that he gives why
no
there are i suppose a number of reasons
that would have contributed to it
uh his solid germanic background
uh
the
the flavor and atmosphere and culture of
baltimore
uh in that period
uh the fact that his father owned a
business
which he wanted henry to succeed him in
uh so that his father was in at least a
modest sense of the word a capitalist
and you know mankind believed in in the
virtues of
capitalism
and uh
bourgeois values
very much did he make any money in his
life
uh
yes he did
uh you know he would he was uh one of
those very rare creatures a financially
successful author
now obviously he did not get the kind of
advances on his books that are given on
some books today
in fact he didn't believe in advances he
never took one
he took his royalties when the book had
been published and was selling but he
never took an advance in his life
uh
that and uh what he earned from the sun
papers for being a columnist and an
editorial advisor
uh plus the fact that uh
you know his father had left the family
pretty well uh
taken care of at his death so omega
never had any real really serious money
worries
the american mercury
was a publication that lasted how long
uh well if you're asking how long it
lasted it came down to relatively modern
uh recent times
uh the great mankind period
began in 1924
and he resigned the editorship of it in
1933. what did it look like it was a
magazine with an arsenic green cover
uh this cover was uniform from beginning
to end as far as color was concerned
uh and general design although the
design was changed a little bit
over the years
and who wrote for it
oh an enormous number of people
it was primarily devoted to political
and social commentary
some literary criticism some fiction and
poetry but not much
uh
you know it dealt with the
social political
economic problems of that era
and
many people
many writers contributed to it
it has been said that
it was a one-man magazine which it was
really it reflected menkin's personality
and anybody whose ideas differed from
menkins uh wouldn't have much chance of
getting published in it
uh it was even said that men can rewrote
the articles that were contributed to it
uh so that they would reflect his views
he himself denied this and i believe
that his denial you know was sincere uh
i i don't think he would have changed
other people's writings
but but the articles that appeared had
to be in agreement with his own
philosophy
let's go back to your work on this uh
this book first of all let's see it
sells for thirty dollars yes expensive
yes it is
any trouble selling it you know
uh i think it has been selling pretty
well i i don't have any figures on it
but
in baltimore and washington when it came
out the early part of last month
booksellers could not keep it in stock
did the publisher tell you why they put
such a high
premium on it
uh no but you know i think that's fairly
standard for
books in today's market
you started on this in 1987
when did you finish it
uh the completed manuscript was probably
turned in about september of 1989.
[Music]
how did you go about no september of
1988 i'm sorry
how did i go about how did you go about
doing this well as i said first of all i
had to make a selection right from the
total how did you do that did you read
every word oh yes yes i had to how long
did that take you
not long
uh a matter of a few weeks
uh
and the the the job of making this
selection was not all that difficult
uh you you may wonder what's in the
other two thirds it's part that i didn't
use
but but really what's in it uh you know
is more complaints about his health
uh he was a member of the board of
directors of the a.s able company the
publishers of the baltimore sun papers
and the director of alfred a knopf
incorporated his publisher and many of
the entries are a little more than
minutes of board meetings with these
companies
and a very little interest to anybody
today
so you point out that actually his
his writing about the board meetings
were better than the minutes themselves
they probably were
i'm sure they were
but anyhow you know those things i
pulled out well i tried to give as
representative
a glimpse as i could of all his
activities
you know as an author
as a newspaper man as a family man
uh
as a friend of authors and musicians and
so on
and you know this is what you have
in in this volume
then of course i have to settle down to
the job of annotating
because many of the people he mentions
most i suppose
many of the events he talks about
would have meant little or nothing to
today's readers
so i had to provide an enormous amount
of well a relatively enormous amount of
annotation
at the bottom of every page
explaining who so and so was
or what this refers to that sort of
thing
where did you do that everything was
done at the pratt library in baltimore i
never had to go anyplace else for any
information i needed
and as you were doing this who helped
you
make sure that uh i mean who edited you
well no one really until i submitted the
manuscript to the publisher
you the reason i ask you that is you
mentioned uh in the introduction
um
i owed you vincent fitzpatrick
assistant curator of pratt's mink and
rome
who knows more about its contents than
any other person on earth
with him i could discuss any problem
that arose any doubt in my mind this is
what i want to ask you about he read the
first draft of this introduction
disagreed vigorously with some of the
things in it what did he disagree with
well
you know i i don't remember all of them
because this was more than a year ago
but what kind of things i mean what
i assume is he a real expert on h.l
mexico yes yes indeed he is uh he
disagreed with my flat statement of
mankind with anthony sendley
among other things that's just one
example
and why would he based on what you read
here that it's rather clear how he feels
about i can't say
yeah are there people that are worried
that this will do great damage to h.l
making them oh there are yes no question
about it and will it
that's pretty hard to say
uh my own fear when when the book
hit the stands
and all the hullabaloo started
was that it might permanently
damage his reputation
uh now i'm not so sure i i really
believe
that he he will survive
in spite of
the new i the new material has come out
about him
uh
i say that because
the american language for example is
still one of the greatest works of
scholarship of our time
his three volume autobiography today's
books still makes the most delightful
reading you can imagine
uh he still remains one of the most
important and influential critics in the
first half of this century
uh all that is there and you know the
things in the diary don't change that
so i i don't think
uh
that it's going to permanently damage
his reputation obviously
uh scholars who write about him from now
on future biographers and critics are
going to have to take what is in there
into consideration
and deal with it
as they see fit
uh
but you know i still think his
reputation will survive now if somebody
wants to go see the rest of these
diaries for any reason is it available
are they available
uh they're in the private library you
know you would have to be engaged in
some kind of scholarly research
involving them to to get permission to
see them so you just can't walk in and
say i want to see the rest of them no
why are they so cautious with that why
don't they bind them
put them in a on the shelf and let
anybody come in and look at them
uh
because well first of all the re the
reason they didn't let anybody see them
originally
was because you know there was always
the thought in mind that eventually they
might be published
and the library wished to hold their
contents
in the reserve until such time as it was
published
now that a portion of it has been
uh
the restrictions so far as i am aware
still apply
on the re the unused portion of it
because there's always the possibility
that some day
the diary may be published in its
entirety uh there are no plans for this
at the moment
but somewhere down the road a university
press
may want to publish the total diary
in a relatively limited edition for the
use of scholars
and
for that reason
you know the library is holding on to
them
who gets the profits front library
and what do they do with that is it go
does it go right into the menken section
of the library or does it or do you know
i i really can't answer that question is
if you go to the pratt library what kind
of a
area is set aside from menken alone
there is a mangan room on the third
floor what's in it
uh
mankin kept every sheet of paper i think
that he ever
typed on in that room are
the volumes bound in blue morocco
bindings which must have been extremely
expensive even then
of all his books
all his magazine articles and newspaper
columns
i i spoke of the monday articles which
ran from 1920 to 1938 there are 18 big
volumes
each one containing a year's monday
articles his original manuscripts and
the
cutouts
of the article from the paper
uh
there's an enormous amount of
correspondence
and then his personal library
of quite a few thousand volumes was also
bequeathed by him and is in the banking
room
here's a photograph of him um with a
cigar in his mouth is that
one of his trademarks oh yes yes he
always had a cigar in his mouth where is
this picture taken that is in his second
floor study at the house on holland
street
looking out the the front window across
to union square
across the street what have they done
with this house his house is now a
baltimore city museum
it has been restored
so far as possible to the what it was
when he and his brother august lived
there
uh it is open to the public
right now an effort is being there was a
picture you showed earlier of him in the
backyard garden
right now they're trying to restore that
garden to what it was in his time
when he was a reporter
um and what were the years that he
actually did reporting for the baltimore
paper well he went to work about 1900
for the baltimore morning herald which
is long since extinct
uh the herald folded up i think about
1906
and he went to work for the sun papers
and was with them
until
his stroke in 1948 would he actually
physically go out i mean like for
instance would he come to washington and
talk to presidents and senators and
congressmen or did he just write his
opinion
uh he interviewed many of the important
politicians and statesmen of this time
uh but
very early
he shot up so fast in the newspaper
business
uh you know that he in a relatively
short time he was uh in a managerial and
supervisory capacity
so he
he did relatively little
newspaper reporting in the course of his
life he would under he would undertake
certain assignments for example he
always covered the national
political conventions the democratic and
republican conventions
matter of fact uh we have a photographer
from the national republican convention
in this uh how many entries are there in
the the diary here that you've done
how many entries different days that he
writes about well i really have no idea
what the number of entries are
what about your favorites
oh i i have some favorites of course
uh one is the long and very beautiful
entry
on may the 31st 1940 the 50th the fifth
anniversary of his wife's death
uh
between the time that she died and that
entry there is no mention
of the fact in the diary at all you
wouldn't even know that uh
she had died in fact you wouldn't know
you've been married and then on may 31
1940 he writes this beautiful and very
long entry about her life together
about how much she meant to him about
her travels together and so on
that would certainly be one of my
favorites
uh there's one about a trip that he and
a friend of his joseph hergersheim are a
novelist of the period
uh made through the pennsylvania dutch
country which is very interesting
uh
and of course you know he
in new york he met for lunch or dinner
novelists like theodore dreiser
poets like edgar lee
masters his accounts of uh you know
having a meal with them and what they
talked about
are fascinating who did he like the most
in people
who yeah what kind of people did he like
he writes a lot about people he didn't
like yeah
uh
you know i i don't know if you can
generalize and say you know what kind of
person he liked
uh
he was obviously
drawn to writers or who's or who were
his closest friends
writers
uh
journalists and musicians and doctors
his attitude toward black people was a
curious mingling of total
of total egalitarianism on the one hand
and patronizing superiority on the other
you say that uh things just didn't make
sense that he had people that work for
him that he was tremendously kind to
that's right
what did you conclude tell us more about
that
uh menken
published black writers in the american
mercury at a time when there were very
few markets
for the work of black writers
he encouraged his publisher alfred knuff
to bring out their books
uh he played a very important part
an inspirational part
in the harlem renaissance of the 1920s
uh he knew and was on friendly terms
with and corresponded with many
important black people of that period
uh and you know he he and his brother
had two black women who
cooked and cleaned for them
and
obviously he was very fond of them took
the most complete care of them
did he pay their medical bills if they
got sick
uh know uh
here you have what i call the
egalitarianism
but at the same time
uh
there's no question but he thought that
black people
uh were inferior to white
uh you know and speaking of these two
black women who worked for him
uh he speaks of their belonging to the
afro-american race and bearing many of
its psychological stigmata
and you quote him as saying here in the
introduction it is impossible he held to
talk about this is quoting to talk about
anything resembling discretion or
judgment in a colored woman they are all
essentially childlike and even hard
experienced does not teach them anything
now are you going to ask me to explain
the paradox here
not necessarily i mean you want to go
right ahead uh no i can't yeah uh he was
a complex and contradictory person
guess what i really wanted to ask you
was um
do you expect
journalists now in the world we live in
today to be able to sort through all
this and in the end accept him
and still revere him as one of the great
journalists of all time
uh
you know i i myself in spite of the fact
that i have been a menken buff all my
life
uh and admire him and enjoy him
tremendously you know i i would not say
that i revere him
and i wouldn't expect anybody else to
revere him
uh but you know i i would expect
somebody else and especially journalists
uh to respect him for his tremendous
abilities as a journalist and writer
do you think that a lot of journalists
who would use his name all the time as
being one of their idols as a writer
really knew
the story here that you
tell in this book
no they did not
what's that say about journalists
and their ability to investigate
anything
well perhaps so but you have to remember
that they had no access to this anyway
but you said when we started this that
it should come as no surprise if you'd
ever read menken over the years
yes that's right there are
indications of anti-semitism
and of his feelings about black people
scattered here and there in his
published writings
but you know i i think that most of us
you know i was one of them
uh i just skimmed over this and ignored
it
and did not let it get in the way of our
admiration for him
have you done much
talking about this book have you
traveled much with it or is this thing
just taken off on its own it's pretty
much taken off on its own i've had quite
a few interviews
uh
and news with newspaper people and uh
radio talk shows and on television
what are the questions you're asked the
most often
uh how do i account for the
anti-semitism and the racism
is
if somebody gets this book and looks in
it are there going to be some surprises
based on you know lots i mean i've got
to hear a stack of
paper
all the reviews and everything's been
done but are people going to be
surprised by things that have not even
been touched
i mean are there major stories in here
from your perspective that no one's
written about that
no no i wouldn't say so no no major
stories
you know uh
this is not going to make previous
biographies and studies of making
obsolete you know uh
as i said in my introduction
uh it tells us things about him that we
had not hitherto known but it doesn't
tell us anything basically different
uh
you know what it adds it it adds in
in detail not not in any major
revelations
there's another thing that caught my eye
you say has um
that
the story goes that he once read his own
obituary in the sun files meaning the
baltimore sun files approved it
and directed that a single sentence be
added at the end quote as he got older
he got worse
and then you say this was undoubtedly
true what did you mean by that oh
there's no question that he became very
crotchety
and stubborn and set in his ways
uh
he must not have been an easy person to
get along with
uh you know he
he was one of the great humorists of the
time and i think he was this
in person as well as in print
for the most part i don't think he ever
lost his his good humor
or
his
ability to relate to people in his
uh generosity and politeness too
uh but he did become said in his ways
that there were certain things that you
know he believed
and uh
the rest of the world believed otherwise
which meant that the rest of the world
was wrong and he was right
uh and uh
you know
he just became a
crotchety as i said and said in his ways
you said he was a conservative yes
is there conservative dogma that he
writes about that becomes
mankind generate or is he just is it he
just comments from a conservative point
of view or do you find that
he just comments from a conservative
point of view
uh you know if you could reduce his
political philosophy to a sentence or
two
uh he was in total agreement with thomas
jefferson
that's the best form of government is
that which governs least
uh mankind thought that uh
a government had no business whatever
uh intruding into the lives of its
people the government existed for two
things to repel foreign invaders and to
maintain domestic order and tranquility
and this was the source of his hatred of
franklin d roosevelt
who came along and created yeah uh the
ccc the nra the nlrb
uh you know all these other government
agencies
the social security act
uh welfare
and so on and you know uh all of this to
mankind was anathema
because he didn't believe the government
had any business
in such areas you said when we started
this that he was very german and i'm not
sure he said it that way but that that
meant a lot to him what did that what
does that mean to you how do you
translate that so we can understand what
that means uh menken's whole background
and culture was german
uh
three of his four
grandparents were german
his father and mother were
uh he he grew up
and actually in those days a great deal
of the baltimore population was german
uh he he grew up absorbing german ideas
in german culture
uh the germany that he loved i think
that you know an important distinction
has to be made here
was the germany of bach beethoven
schubert brahms
german beer
this sort of thing
uh so it was hard for him
to feel both in world war one and again
in world war ii
to feel any strong anti-german
sentiments
uh at the same time you know i think it
would be wrong to say that he was
pro-nazi
nothing in his writings gives the
slightest indication that he
approved of what hitler was doing in
germany
it has to be admitted he never wrote
anything against it and he should have
of course
why he didn't
is a mystery that you know no no writer
about him no one who knew him has ever
been able to explain
you point out and and as i look through
the
your book to find it uh there is no
entry around december the 7th 1941
that's right there is no entry around ve
or vj day that's right how come
uh
[Music]
again i don't know
uh there is an entry where he talks
about the the end of the war
i don't know whether it was ve day or
the vj day my impression it was a ve uh
but
the the only uh
the matter with which the entry deals is
the the noise that all the people are
making around the neighborhood
while he was working
celebrating the end of the war did he
ever talk about war
well he talks about it here and there in
the diary yes
but but mainly uh
to the extent that it has has had very
little effect on him it hasn't changed
his way of life very much or conversely
that it's inconveniencing him in this
way or that
last question what impact
has baltimore had both on you and on him
can you tell us
something about baltimore that's
different from other places that you
know
uh
let me try to quote area h.l menken
looks like and it's edited by charles
fetcher
we thank you for joining us thank you
for inviting me
charles fetcher is editor of the diary
of h.l menken you can visit the
publisher's website at
randomhouse.com the book is currently
out of print if you're interested in
purchasing a used copy they're available
from several online booksellers
h.l menken was scheduled to be the focus
of this week's american writers
but due to current events american
writers will not be broadcast this
monday